it's extremely alarming to see so many
millions of people
extremely worried about uh heating and
eating so liberal democrats have argued
first of all the government shouldn't
have cut the universal credit uplift
they should have been more generous they
also shouldn't be going ahead with this
increase in the tax on jobs which is
going to leave both employees and
employers uh worse off
and they should be actually uh
addressing this energy price crisis i
have argued that there should be a robin
hood tax a windfall tax on the super
profits of the gas companies who are
just making out with the global gas
prices going up and that money some of
that money should go to the more
vulnerable in society um i've argued
that the pensioner winter fuel announced
should be doubled and something called
the warm home discount which helps
people taking money directly off their
bills that that should be doubled and
many more people should get it so we've
got some practical measures that the
liberal democrats have put forward but
the government just seems in total
inertia completely incapable of taking
any leadership but i mean there are
proposals also that have been put
forward uh by labor i mean certainly a
windfall tax on oil and gas some saying
that could lead to higher to less
investment sorry in oil and gas which
then of course would lead to higher
prices so not necessarily solving the
problem and then on the warm homes
discount the issue there could be this
is already an industry managed scheme
that's in place it normally the way it
works would be uh that those who can
afford or or well in in the old days
could afford uh would pick up the bill
for the poorest uh households but the
problem is what we're going to see is
the squeezed middle suddenly having more
put on their bills in order to double
the warm home homes discount for those
who can't afford and you're suddenly
seeing a squeezed middle that are no
longer a squeeze middle they're falling
down and down the pecking order it it
feels like we need something far more
systemic to try and deal with the cost
of living crisis than these sorts of
measures that have been put forward i
mean are there any other creative uh
measures that that any parties coming up
with at the moment
well first of all i've got to disagree
with you quite strongly about your
characterization of of what we think is
a really ambitious policy to help people
who are struggling the warm home
discount you're right
is currently coming off the bills and in
in terms of other bill payers paying for
it under our proposals that money would
have to be paid for by the taxpayer so
you'd actually reduce everybody's bills
because this cost that's currently paid
through bills which are quite right
would come off and on to the taxpayer
funded by this robin hood tax and you
said earlier that it would be difficult
for gas companies because they'd curb
investment simply not true
windfall taxes by their very nature
don't impact investment plans these
super profits that the gas companies are
making because of this unexpected rise
in gas prices will not impact their
investment uh at all they're just as the
chief executive bp said they're acting
like a cash machine that's unfair it's
unfair that these gas companies are
making such profits when people are
having to choose between heating and
eating so i say again the liberal
democrat proposal which was actually
significantly before labour but i'll let
that buy and please labour now saying
the same thing the opposition party is
saying the same thing to government we
have some real proposals here funded
proposals to really help those people
who will be struggling
should more be done absolutely they
shouldn't be going ahead with this
unfair rise in this jobs tax they're
proposing there are other things that
can be done
but i think first of all the government
should adopt liberal democrat policy
which is really radical and will make a
big difference quickly all right well i
want to get you on to what we originally
asked you to talk about today uh which
is the parties uh in downing street the
potential uh delay against the sugree
report whilst we wait for the
metropolitan police uh to to do their
investigation on twitter you've called
it a stitch up between the met
leadership and number 10. what do you
mean by that
well let's be clear i have nothing but
respect for the rank-and-file police
officers who put their lives in danger
every day to keep us safe and that's why
i'm worried about any growing perception
of a stitch-up it's pretty dangerous i
mean let's look what's happened the met
originally said they would not
retrospectively investigate these issues
they said they wouldn't do it then they
said they might but they would read the
sue grey report after it had been
published then they changed for a third
time and said they would investigate but
sue gray should publish in full first
and then they changed their minds again
at the last minute and said we and and
therefore we now have this long delay
before the sue grey report uh is
published it's an utter fiasco uh and
it's got to stop uh and that's why
liberal democrats are going to call this
out um number 10 has behaved appallingly
we all know that and these delays just
make it seem a lot lot worse but when
you say stitch up between met leadership
and number 10 are you suggesting there's
some sort of collusion between the two
um listen i think people just losing
confidence because this has been badly
handled i wrote to the met commissioner
cresser dick weeks ago
calling on the net police to investigate
if they had done that when i first
called for it the investigation would
have been finished and we could have
moved on with the results of in fact
both investigations that's why i think
you know it's right for opposition
parties to really question what is going
on um you know the whole of the
government is in chaos at the moment
it can't make decisions about the cost
of living we're just talking about the
cost of living
the government coming forward with no
package to help people because they're
too busy worrying about their own skins
because this has been so badly handled
i want to ask you i wonder because i
know you know i know from from reading
what you've said that uh your priority
is to get boris johnson out you'd like
him to resign you've been wanting him to
resign for a while um in if that is your
aim what would be so bad about waiting
until the met concludes its report to go
alongside the sue gray report uh
potentially that could be more damaging
for the prime minister or are you
concerned that the metropolitan police
report is going to exonerate the prime
minister
i think that's highly unlikely i mean i
think really the issue is these delays
in reports being published when we know
they've been completed for several days
is worrying people um if the met police
had got on with the job when i asked
them to
we would already have the report and i
think it's those delays that are
beginning to sound alarm bells across
westminster and whitehall in the whole
country frankly and i'm not the only one
who is expressing alarm at the delays i
mean i don't get me wrong having called
for the met police to investigate i
welcome the fact that they are
investigating but i'm worried that uh we
were told that the sue grey report could
be published and it wouldn't interfere
with the investigation now people have
changed their minds all of a sudden you
can understand why people might be
getting a little bit worried